- [Instructor] By the
time the antidote arrived,
87 days late, the men had
already turned to stone.
So I don't know what
type of problem they had,
but turning to stone,
that seems pretty serious.
But let's look at the grammar of it.
So it's underlined.
By the time the antidote arrived, dash,
87 days late, dash, the men
had already turned to stone.
So this seems like a
pretty good use of dashes.
87 days late, it's a parenthetical,
they're giving us a little
bit of extra information
that is not necessary for the sentence.
You could remove, you
could take this part out
right over here, you
could take this part out,
and it won't, it would still be a sentence
that gives the same meaning.
By the time the antidote arrived
the men had already turned to stone.
So you could do that, but
adding that 87 days late
gives you a little, it gives
you some extra information,
it gives you some extra context
for what's going on here.
So this parenthetical, it seems
like a good place to do it,
and it seems good to do it with dashes.
This 87 days late, hey, that's a pretty
strong thing that you
would wanna insert in there
to add some important
context to the sentence,
and you'd want the dash on both sides.
So I like it the way that it's written.
Now, these other choices.
You wouldn't want to start with
a comma and end with a dash,
and you wouldn't want to start
with a dash and end with a comma.
And you need something to separate it off.
You wouldn't say, by the
time the antidote arrived
87 days late the men had
already turned to stone.
This right over here, this
right here is a parenthetical.
You could put parentheses around it.
But I actually like putting dashes here,
because it's very important context.
A parentheses, that's for a parenthetical.
Hey maybe it's nice to know,
it's kind of a cute thing,
you could make a little bit of an aside.
But dashes are, hey, this gives
you some powerful context.
The antidote arrived 87 days late.
So I definitely, so this
one, you need some type
of punctuation to mark
off the 87 days late.
So I would rule that one out as well.